like how do you feel about the criticism
that you got some people saying you're
racist after the Netflix well that that
criticism was was because that's why we
brought you home we're like we hope
you're racist
you kind of let me down with this whole
everyone's equal talk yeah
that was interesting uh the the subject
of race is never mentioned in my Netflix
series ancient apocalypse it's never
mentioned at all but when the society
for American archaeologists wrote an
open letter to Netflix demanding that my
documentary Series be class reclassified
as science fiction they accused me of
spreading racism white supremacy
misogyny
and anti-Semitism none of these issues
are ever mentioned in the series wait
what was misogynist yes I don't know and
and uh you know what for that matter was
anti-semitic it's a very and and what
was racist but since races since race is
never mentioned but what these labels
are very useful for if you shout them
loudly enough oh and if your friends in
the media see a nice story here and pick
them up and multiply it what they're
very useful for is turning people off
the work of an opponent yes and that was
that was clearly what went on here if
you're radioactive I don't even have to
debate you because you're radioactive
that's right that's right that's
fundamentally what went on now what did
what is the reason for what was the
possible they had no justification for
any of the others but what was the
reason for saying that I was spreading
racism and white supremacy is because in
a number of my earlier books I reported
indigenous myths and traditions
particularly from South America and from
Mexico which in some cases referred to a
white-skinned beard headed stranger and
his companions who came after a time of
Darkness after a great cataclysm
bringing knowledge and teaching
knowledge to the inhabitants of the
country now that is not me saying that
that is indigenous Traditions the view
of archaeologists today is that many of
those Traditions were simply made up by
the Spanish conquistadors I don't think
that's true there are many there are
many other archaeologists who don't
agree with that and think that they are
true and genuine indigenous traditions
and should be and should be rightly
reported as such whether we're referring
to Quetzalcoatl in Mexico or to
viracocha in the Andes these these
Traditions it's a Pan-American myth and
and they're found they're not only found
in in the Americas but all over the
world they don't always refer to a
person as white skin you know the
emphasis that that's put on skin color
today is a is really recent in human
history it's a few hundred years old uh
did the issue of white skin or black
skin carry the same resonance 12 000
years ago that it carries today I
somehow doubt it I doubt it very much I
don't see why I don't see why it should
because because the the the abuses of
human rights that were taken that were
that were carried out in the name of
color uh are recent developments they're
not ancient developments you know and
and they're listening to a scale of
human history recent in the scale of
human history let's say let's say the
last five or six hundred years some
something like that they weren't they
weren't really there they weren't really
there before that but it's a it's a it's
a huge distraction from from the major
issue
um they also refer to these individuals
as being bearded
um they often refer to there being seven
of them in ancient Mesopotamia they're
called the seven sages uh in ancient
Egypt at the Temple of Horus at edfu
they are also referred to as the seven
sages uh in Ancient India it's Manu and
the seventh and the seven sages who
appear after the flood uh trying to
restore the knowledge that was lost
during the time of the flood these are
indigenous Traditions same story
different parts of the world same story
different parts of the world it's one of
the things that interests me about it
what interests me about it least of all
is the issue of skin color what
interests me about it most of all is the
issue that there there seems to be a
memory of a cataclysm after which a
group of people tried to preserve
knowledge the Snow White myth I'm not
sure she falls asleep Seven Dwarfs so
the seven sages they come wake her up
with the wisdom of a guy should make out
with you when you're passed out I need
to reread the Snow White okay
it might be something there this is good
yeah well well no because because myths
you myths are the memory bank of our
species this is what I loved about the
Netflix special treating the myths as a
way of passing on true information yes
and uh yeah and taking them seriously
not looking at these figments of
imagination if we were to pass on data
in fact it's way more digestible in the
form of story We memorize stories if you
wish to pass message if you wish to pass
information to a distant future if you
wish it to be preserved you wouldn't be
smart to just write it down uh how can
we know that our script is going to be
readable by any other culture let's say
10 000 years in the future will anybody
be able to read the English language who
knows I I have I have no idea it's
fragile an example I often give is the
Indus Valley Civilization in uh Pakistan
and India the the Indus Bali
civilization nobody actually knew that
it existed until it was accidentally
discovered while a railway was built
being built through a site now called
Mohenjo-daro
um in Pakistan and then they found that
there were these actually very very
sophisticated very complex mud mud brick
structures on a very large scale then
they began to look at it then they found
that this culture had had a language a
fully developed written script
it's about 5 000 years old but there
isn't a single
Rosetta Stone that enables us to
translate that script into any more
recent language so we can't read that
script the script exists but we can't
read it so there could be all kinds of
information in that script which should
tell us all kinds of things about our
past but it's not but it's not readable
and how long ago were they thriving 5000
years ago wow one of the interesting
things in the Indus Valley Civilization
is that there there is a particular seal
that has survived a seal that would have
been used to stamp an imprint onto cloth
or something like that it's called the
pasupati seal and it shows a figure
which is which is recognizable as the
god Shiva uh who's of course an
important deity in Indian culture to
this day and and in The Vedas
um and and it shows that individuals
seated in a yeah there you are that's
the person Patty seal well what you'll
see is that is that underneath the way
his feet are organized is that his heels
are pointed forwards uh this is a really
difficult yoga position to sit like that
and have your heels pointed forward
you've got to kind of almost disjoint
your legs in order to do that okay and
the problem the problem with that is
that it's an advanced yoga position it's
found it's found in a seal that's 5 000
years old we have to ask ourselves how
many thousands of years before there's
yoga being developed do you know again
there's a hint of a lost human culture
in this the the posture is called
mulabandasana
um and I certainly can't do it
unbelieved because what do we date
modern Indian civilization back to so
yeah this is 4 000. yeah since the
discovery of the Indus Valley
Civilization you know we have we have to
accept that civilization in in India is
is at least 5 000 years old the the the
the largely and correctly discredited
notion of an Aryan invasion of India
needs to be abandoned as well yes there
were multiple cultures moving moving
back and forwards but Indian culture is
extremely extremely ancient 5 000 years
yeah yeah and and
Valley that's like a thing you'll learn
about in textbooks yeah yeah you learn
about it now accept it yeah but but but
what most people don't realize was
nobody knew it even because it was a
loss and the language is completely
independent there's no connectivity to
anything nobody can nobody can connect
it to anything we don't know we don't
know what it was there's some there's
some suggestion that it may have been
dravidian peoples uh the peoples who are
now found in south primarily in Southern
India people the tamils okay yeah uh as
a matter of fact my wife is is Tamil
um and that's been very helpful to us
where we've been researching in Southern
India we did a lot of diving in so that
my wife is a photographer and a diver as
I am and we did a lot of diving in
Southern India so it was it was great to
be able to talk for her to be able to
talk in their own language to Tamil
fishermen and Tamil divers and see if
they'd seen any weird stuff underwater
which they certainly had and they took
us to diving on on structures that are a
fully formed City off the uh of the town
of muhammadipuram now you speak about
this in the documentary but I think this
is really important to understand as
well that most of human civilization has
been organized around water right close
proximity to water obviously you can
fish travel Etc and as the water levels
change some of those ancient cities
could be completely covered yeah you've
recovered some of these you've seen this
is one of the things that I think is
that I think is missing from our
understanding of the past
uh it amused me but also irritated me
that that in that open letter to Netflix
The Society for American archaeologists
claimed that they could absolutely for
certain be sure that there was no Lost
Civilization during the Ice Age they
knew it was a fact and if there had been
any civil that they would have found it
and they would have published it right
well how do they know that how did they
know that there was no Lost Civilization
then because uh it's really important to
understand that archeology
is often driven by accidental fines a
lot of archeology particularly in the
industrialized countries
is the result of somebody building
building there's a huge building project
going in maybe a Housing state is going
to be built maybe a road is going to be
built maybe a railway is going to be
built uh maybe a dam is going to be
built and then let's see let's call in
the archaeologist to make sure that
we're not going to wreck any ancient
archeology while we're doing this and
that's a lot of archaeological
discoveries are made as a result of that
right rather than have targeted
inquiries the second issue with ruling
out completely the possibility of A Lost
Civilization is that archeology sets
itself up as the sole Arbiter as to what
is and what is not evidence so I and my
colleagues argue that we should consider
the possibility of a much older Great
Sphinx as we've just been discussing uh
on the on the basis of its geology
I'm just going to add a more complicated
point it's not only the geology the
Great Sphinx points perfectly due east
the sun rises perfectly due east on the
Spring Equinox if you go to the Giza
Plateau or anywhere else in the world on
the summer Northern Hemisphere on the
summer solstice you're going to see the
sun rising far to the North of East go
there on the winter sources you're going
to see it far to the south of East but
on the Spring Equinox it rises perfectly
due east directly in line with the Gaze
of the Sphinx the Sphinx is looking at
where the sun rises at dawn on the 21st
of March in our calendar
now
because of this wobble on the Earth's
axis what is that called again the
wobble it's called precession precession
imagine a spinning top which is which is
spinning and and is doing and it's kind
of doing this and that's the viewing
platform from which we observe the stars
and the Sun and the Moon and everything
else and obviously the changes in its
orientation are going to change their
orientation and that's why why we get
the the
um astrological ages again mainstream
science snares of these things but it is
a simple astronomical fact that there
are 12 constellations that lie along the
path of the sun which is called the
ecliptic and they are the constellations
of the zodiac and right now we live in
the age of Pisces very near the end of
the age of Pisces
um it's um the simple fact that the
ancient Christians uh go back about 2
000 years ah the fish they the fish was
their thing uh before that it was Aries
the ram ancient Egyptian symbolism at
that time was very much focused on on
Rams uh go back before that it's the age
Taurus roughly the pyramid age that's
when that's that's why if you were
building a huge 270 foot long Rock human
monument in the pyramid age you'd be
more likely to make it in the form of a
bull
of a lion yeah of a lion because there
is a time when you go back guess when
about 12 000 years that you find it's
the constellation of Leo that is rising
behind the sun that's the that's the age
of Leo just as we live in the age of
Pisces that was the age of Leo and there
was a time when that Monument would have
looked directly at the place where the
sun rises first it would have seen its
own Celestial counterpart the
constellation of Leo sitting on the
horizon and then the sun rising beneath
it so to to us this uh and I I speak of
myself Robert baval Robert shock John
Anthony West and a few others we think
it makes more sense take the geology
take the astronomy this Monument has its
Origins 12 000 years ago but
egyptologists say no we know these
things was built 4 500 years ago uh the
I'm not going to bore your audience with
the details but the evidence is
incredibly flimsy there isn't a single
document that attributes the Great
Sphinx to Cafe who is supposed to be the
builder of the gray swing so there's
nothing it's just opinion pure opinion
uh and and we think that that they are
not right to dismiss the case for a much
older Sphinx and to say that so they
have the they select what evidence is
evidence and what evidence isn't
evidence uh that's the the second thing
and then the third and final thing is
that huge areas of the world that have
never been looked at by archeology at
all or if looked at by archeology looked
at only minimally of course the most
important are the flooded Continental
shelves and that's why Santa and I spent
seven years of Our Lives
frequently risking our lives uh scuba
diving all around the world sea level
Rose 400 feet at the end of the last ice
age let's be clear it did not rise 400
feet overnight right this was a rise
that was extended over a period of 11 or
12 000 years from about 21 000 years ago
down to 10th it was even still Rising
about six thousand years ago all over
the world all over the world yeah there
was a global the old world's oceans are
connected and all also but but in local
areas if you have a very steep Coastline
the effect of the sea level rise at the
amount of land it eats up is going to be
a lot less than if you have a gradually
sloping Coastline and and 120 feet level
sea level rise on a very steep bit of
coast is going to remove relatively less
land whereas on a very sloping bit of
Coast uh it's going to it's going to
inundate much more land and the
calculation is that 27 million square
kilometers that was above water during
the Ice Age is underwater now roughly I
think that's roughly 10 million square
miles I can't do the math in my hand but
something like that it's an awful lot of
land I think it's Europe and China added
together uh there it's it's not that
there's been no archeology done on the
Continental shelves I think we're
looking at something from Alexandria
here yes yeah we are we are I've dived
there as well
um and and that's um that's inundated
not because of sea level rise but
because of subsidence of the Nile silts
uh off the the Alexandria stands on the
Nile Delta and the the silt subsided and
resulted
uh the Nile carries a lot of silt with
it a lot of Earth with it as it flows
out of Uganda and out of Ethiopia and
northwards into Egypt and you come to
the Nile Delta and all that Earth it's
carrying which also provided the
fertility of ancient Egypt all that silt
is then dumped in the Nile Delta and
there were constructions were made on
top of it and those that the the
submergence of the sites off Alexandria
which is a magical spooky place to dive
by the way I've been lucky enough to
dive there the submergence of those
sites is largely because of subsidence
of land rather than sea level rise
because it's relatively recent those
those so if you're saying the silt
itself has dropped yeah yeah right
yeah built on top of it went down